12 الف دولار امريكي قيمه اغلى هديه
تلقاها الرئيس الجو بايدن عام 2021 ضمن
تقليدا يتبع في الاعراف الدبلوماسيه
والدوليه لتبادل الهدايا بين الرؤساء
والمسؤولين الرقم ليس مفاجئا نظرا لما
كانت الرئيس جو بايدن كرئيسا لاقوى دوله
في العالم ولكن المفاجاه تبقى في صاحب
الهديه
هل انتم مستعدون انه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ولا احد غيره
[موسيقى]
لم تمنع التوترات بين بيض وبوتين من تبادل
الهدايا في جناب عام 2021 فاهدى بايدن
زوجا من نظراته الشمسيه افيتر للرئيس
بوتين الذي رد عبر منح مجموعه مكتب من
المنمنمات المطليه على اليد التي تمثل
اقدم الفنون الروسيه الاثريه وتبلغ قيمتها
12000 دولار لكن السعر في هذه الحاله لن
يكون له علاقه بقوه علاقتهما الفعليه فبعد
الثمانيه اشهر بدات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتحول الرجلان لغريمين في السياسه
هديه بوتين لم تكن الوحيده التي تلقاها
بعيدا عام 2021 فبحسب التقرير السنوي
لوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه تلقى بايدن
هدايا من الملكات البريطانيه الراحله
اليزابيث عباره عن صوره لها في اطار فضي
تبلغ قيمتها
2200 دولار
[موسيقى]
كما اعطى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني انذاك
بورس جونسون لبايدن زوجا من اطباق للكلاب
وفي صيفي 2021 اهدى اشرف غني رئيس
افغانستاني انذاك بايدن سجاده حريريه
بقيمه تسعه الاف دولار بينما اهدى زوجته
جلب سجاده حريريه اخرى بقيمه
19.200 دولار في بطون اسابيع كان غني يفر
من البلاد بعد ان استولت طالبا على كابول
بعد انسحاب القوات الامريكيه من افغانستان
الهدايا ترمز للتعاون الدولي والصداقه بين
دول وقاده غالبا ما تفصل بينهم محيطات
وايديولوجيات مع العلم ان معظم هذه
الهدايا تسلم للارشيف الوطني ما لم يدفع
قيمتها الرئيس ومع ذلك لا تزال بعض
الهدايا مفقوده خاصه تلك التي قدمت للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ريتا سليمان لصباح
العربيه واشنطن